it was 1965 and the chicago pd was
investigating a meatpacking plant
reported to be the home of a
devil-worshipping cult
complete with allegations of human
sacrifice there the cops were met with
heavy resistance
a firefight broke out between the police
and the occult worshipers who flooded
out of the plant's basement
the cops were pinned down and in trouble
but they had
a secret weapon heavily armed and decked
out in sophisticated ballistic armor
and covered in strange insignia mobile
task force epsilon 9
also known as the fire eaters here to
assist the cops on behalf of the scp
foundation as always with the foundation
they had no interest in some mere human
cultists
those were a dime a dozen in the world
of anomalous monsters
what the foundation had taken an
interest in was who
or what these cultists were worshiping
it all began a few weeks back
near danforth meat packing an abandoned
meat packing plant just outside of
chicago
no one had given the place a thought in
decades that is
until people started going missing
rumors spread of people being snatched
in the surrounding woods by figures
dressed in robes
mysterious voices and noises were said
to be coming out from the cavernous
belly of the planet
some even reported seeing smoke rising
out of the building
thick black noxious smoke
something was terribly wrong here
something was
anomalous the chicago police
department's strike force
in association with the fire eaters from
the foundation mobilized at danforth
meat packing
while the police were initially
reluctant to work with these mysterious
figures
they turned out to be indispensable for
the raid there were 47 cultists holding
out in the basement of the plant
many of them heavily armed and all of
them hopped up on zealous devotion to
their unknown master
all except one of the cultists fought to
the death during a tense firefight with
chicago pd
and the fire eaters the single survivor
was still heavily injured
and was taken to a secure foundation
facility for emergency treatment and
debriefing
typically the foundation would need to
perform extensive tests on the danforth
meatpacking plant to discover the source
of the anomalies activity
however this time it was a chicago
detective who asked the question that
busted the case wide open
ah the hell's with the giant pig and
while it would turn out to be a whole
lot more than that
there was indeed a giant iron furnace
shaped like a pig in the center of the
facility
measuring 15 meters by 25 meters by 20
meters at its widest point
the thing was a behemoth it had an
internal furnace despite no apparent
fuel source
and a five-centimeter slot of unknown
purpose on the side of the machine's
immense rusted hide
naturally all the police officers
involved in the raid had their memories
wiped and restructured
and they were lucky because they'd
remain forever ignorant of the true
horrors about to unfold in the confines
of that godforsaken factory
as is standard procedure the plant was
isolated and a foundation research team
led by lead researcher westron under the
authority of regional director caleb
was installed on the new provisional
site to conduct tests
other than everyone feeling somewhat
uneasy around it
this new anomaly dubbed scp-4511 didn't
seem to exhibit any strange activities
save for its perpetually burning fire
but during the initial research period a
small white card suddenly popped out of
the slot in scp-4511
sign a researcher carefully approached
and looked at the card
there was writing it said current demand
a flock of my own satisfied
though nobody on the team had any idea
what this meant
after going through a shootout with a
considerable death toll to get to it
having a giant metal pig shaped furnace
spit out a cryptic card was strange
but at the secret medical facility where
the surviving cultist was being held
things were about to get a whole lot
stranger
as he lay in a bed suffering from his
injuries he pulled one of the medical
staff
close and uttered cryptic dying words
give whatever it demands
or your suffering will be beyond measure
he expired
seconds later less than 72 hours after
the raid
back at the meatpacking plant at the
exact same time
another white card was produced by the
machine
reading current demand the metal teeth
that endlessly churn
period one week perhaps this entity was
a little more intelligent than they
thought
a number of researchers on the team
invigorated by this new development
were eager to press forward with
experiments lead researcher western
however did not share their enthusiasm
something about this entire situation
felt like a grim
omen to him this entity had a plan far
beyond their understanding
and on some deep animal level he knew
that helping this thing
see its plans through would lead to
disastrous results
on this first gut impulse he denied the
request for further experiments
but regional director caleb had other
ideas
caleb overruled western's command and
the experiments began
shortly after the entity jokingly
nicknamed the swine god by researchers
had made its demand
the metal teeth that endlessly churn but
what could that mean
it wasn't long before the entity began
to produce more cards
each with their own strange and esoteric
demands
however on some instinctual level the
researchers at the site understood the
demands perfectly
the next card's demand was the mettle of
this suffocating prison upon receiving
this demand
researchers collected scrap metal from
around the new site
and tossed them into the furnace beyond
the swine god's jaws
one by one inside they heard the sound
of metal crunching
hours later all the other metal in the
site began to rapidly oxidize and rust
though scp-4511 itself remained
unaffected
the car that came after delivered
another simple request
oil to slicken my frozen joints
the researchers understood and procured
three large barrels of oil and tossed
them into the furnace
the entity let out a deep gurgle before
shaking violently and expelling excess
oil
rusted metal and two domesticated pig
femurs
it turns out that the swine god had an
appetite for pigs
as the next card that rumbled out of the
machine bore the request
two of my children made in my image
made in flesh in response the
researchers provided the entity with two
adult pigs
just like the previous requests they too
were tossed into the fiery depths of the
giant pig's mouth
from which came the horrible sounds of
pigs squealing
and then a low guttural gurgling next
the request was the hooks used to hang
my children's corpses
to satisfy this request the researchers
provided 17
meat books in response 4511 spat out a
metal sphere at an extremely high
velocity
killing observing foundation agent
mchenry for reasons that weren't
apparent at the time
rather than giving agent mchenry a
proper burial his body was also
fed into the hungry machine lead
researcher western's concerns were
mounting
but that didn't amount to much now 4511
had developed a taste for flesh
and the researchers were all too eager
to obey
its command on the swine gods order it
was fed a german shepherd
an hour later the entity spat out some
teeth six of which came from a dog
and one from a human more than once it
released a card with a blunt request
a worker for the line the researchers
knew exactly what this meant
it required a human sacrifice scp-4511
was given two d-class personnel
one was flung back out seconds later
crunched and burned to death with
several internal organs missing
the other had a more mysterious and
altogether upsetting fade
the second d-class was heard screaming
in the belly of the furnace for roughly
two hours
thirty-four minutes later a strange
liquid was excreted by the machine
when the liquid was tested they found
trace amounts of chemicals like pig
urine and motor oil
but most disturbing of all human genetic
material that was identical to that of
lead researcher western
it seemed that the swine god had finally
taken an interest in him
after some final requests for large
quantities of coal
and even human children to fuel its
fires
it made a request that sent the whole
thing crashing down
the false foreman delivered to my ma to
prove your faith
lead researcher western knew what this
meant
they all did the swine god was demanding
him
in sacrifice lead researcher western
tried to shut down the entire project
but the swine god was faster than him
one of his own researchers shot western
in the leg
as the others gathered round and
forcibly restrained him
he tried to reason with his subordinates
but it didn't do him any good
the swine god had crawled into all their
minds and corrupted them
they were his servants now and western
was doomed
despite his protests the servants forced
him into the mouth of scp-4511
and after a little over four minutes of
screaming western was devoured just like
all the other sacrifices
upon receiving news of the horrors
unfolding in the danforth meat packing
plan
regional director caleb declared the
security of the site compromised
and sent in mobile task force epsilon 11
aka the nine-tailed fox
the four elite mtf soldiers were given
the simple instruction to figure out
exactly what had happened
and to eliminate any potentially
compromised foundation staff members
who'd fallen under the swine gods power
when the team arrived they realized just
how far gone
the whole place was almost everyone was
dead
having been sacrificed to the machine
and the ones that were left were
completely insane
they attacked the task force shouting in
their madness about how no matter what
the foundation does to them
it would be nothing compared to what it
would do
it had them all under its rusty iron
foot
the team was forced to fend off repeated
attacks from the pig's devotees
and even found the powers of the swine
gods starting to affect their own minds
the beast was more powerful and
dangerous than anyone had imagined
the train foundation researchers and
guards had been transformed into the
same cultists they fought to gain
control of the building
by the mind-bending power of the swine
god the mtf were forced to retreat
and return with reinforcements to truly
clean the place out
once a slaughterhouse always a
slaughterhouse
at this point regional director caleb
took personal responsibility over the
casualties
since he'd been the one who signed off
on the experiments in the first place
he gave up his regional director rank
and deemed himself the new lead
researcher on the 4511 case
now that he fully understood the scope
and danger of the entity they were
dealing with
he wanted to lead the charge in
discovering more about the anomaly
and hopefully someday negating its
deadly effects
this may sound like a happy ending in
spite of all the violence
bloodshed and human sacrifice that
brought us here
but beware of the premature celebration
despite investigation
the swine god retained no evidence of
the objects
animals and people it consumed and
burned
perhaps it burnt them down to their very
atoms if those even still
existed what we do know is that not long
after
after lead researcher caleb and his
subordinates installed themselves into
the facility
scp-4511 produced one more
little white card it read current demand
a flock of my own satisfied
and if we've learned anything today it's
that the swine god gets whatever it
demands
a brutal truth that lead researcher
caleb is likely to understand much
sooner
than he thought haven't had your fill of
eldritch horrors hiding in disused
buildings
check out our two-parter scp-1730
what happened to site 13 and scp-1730
epic final battle at site 13.